tu as quand même très souvent des
personnes qui me pose la question mais
bien voir comment tu fais pour conduire
regardez c'est très simple la porte je
m'installe
[Applaudissements]
et voilà je vais reprendre très
clairement les mots du médecin qui l'a
utilisé pour qualifier la petite taille
à mes parents pour leur annoncer mon
handicap
c'était bernard ça sera un vin de cirque
il ya un an de cirque et comment on peut
qualifier de personnes comme ça c'est
une ligne ans c'est n'importe quoi
on est des personnes comme tout le monde
je veux dire je travaille pas dans un
cirque
je travaille dans une entreprise normale
dans le secteur de la communication
et voilà mes parents de par leur
éducation
ils m'ont vu comme une personne
entièrement normal et c'est ça qui fait
ma plus grande force parce qu'ils m'ont
appris à me débrouiller au quotidien le
moment où j'ai vraiment pris conscience
de mon handicap je pense que c'est à
l'entrée du cp parce que en maternelle
encore tout est petit tout est à petite
échelle des petites chaises des petites
tables donc même tout l'outil même plus
petit que la norme ça allait encore
par contre quand vous arrivez sur les
bancs du cp et que l'on découvre qu il
faut vraiment se hisser sur la chaise
toutefois remonté sur le bureau là on se
dit ah ya peut être un petit souci
l'adolescence il y avait un point
marquant là dedans ou qui a peut-être
marquer encore plus mon handicap
c'est la période des premiers amours eh
ben la plupart des copines avec qui je
voulais sortir était beaucoup plus
grande
et quand on est à l'adolescence on est
un peu bête
on se construit et on veut pas forcément
sortir avec une personne plus petit
même si j'étais toujours la personne qui
était très gentille
même si j'étais toujours le copain qui
était toujours là
les pôles sur qui on pouvait compter si
jamais on pleurait six géants mais on
avait des soucis coeur mais par contre
moi je savais que j'ai tenté à plusieurs
reprises bombe après on va pas se
leurrer non plus j'ai eu
j'ai vu des coups de coeur j'ai eu des
émois et à chaque fois oui c'était un
refus j'ai fait mon premier bisou à 24
ans voilà j'ai fait mon premier bisou à
24 ans donc c'est vrai que ça fait tard
mais j'avais croisé
j'avais croisé une fille qui était on va
dire plus ouverts d'esprit et à cet âge
là à 24 ans ben non tu tues tu réfléchis
un petit peu plus oui le bonhomme qui
est là et les plus petits mais dans sa
tête c'est une personne normale donc
voilà
et
au travers de mes vidéos j'ai vraiment
envie qu'ils découvrent mon quotidien et
que ces questions là n'existe plus au
fur et à mesure où qu'une personne qui
se retourne sur moi dans la rue quasi
moribond en fait il est petit comme
bernard que je connais il ya des gens
qui vont poser des questions face à des
copains là pour la première réaction des
copains vont dire il complètement bête
poser cette question
non on n'est pas bête il ne sais pas toi
ça fait quinze ans que tu m'as compote
ça fait quinze ans que tu vis a entre
guillemets avec moi ça fait quinze ans
que tu connais mes difficultés
ça fait quinze ans que par exemple quand
je vais au cinéma c'est toi qui me donne
mon ticket parce que là le guichet il
est trop donc est ce que tu fais partie
de mon quotidien donc tu sais comment je
le vis entre ont tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet nous choisir des fringues
déjà dans un premier temps quels sont
les tailles que je choisis alors saisir
non je ma vie pendant huit ans non c'est
pas parce que je suis beau tee que je
vais forcément rentrer dans du 8 ans un
jour j'ai croisé un enfant dans un
supermarché qui est avec sa mère je
faisais mes courses comme une personne
normale
l'enfant a pointé du doigt et a dit sa
maman regarde le monsieur comme il est
petit et en voulant faire de
l'autodérision parce qu'on a le droit de
faire l'autoroute de région je lui ai
dit ça c'est parce que j'ai pas mangé
assez souple donc méfie toi parce que si
tu manges pas de la soupe et lescure est
arrivé la même chose et là la mère est
là la maman elle a exposé de rire elle a
explosé de rire mais gentiment gentiment
et j'ai senti qu'elle rentrait dans mon
jeu et le le gosse il savait plus quoi
dire
ils étaient choqués que sa mère rigolent
ils étaient choqués que moi je rigole
aussi mais à côté de ça la mer est quand
même devenue la maman de l'enfant est
quand même venu me voir derrière et en
me disant est une chose dont je suis sûr
monsieur c'est que si enfin quand il
sera grand
j'espère qu'il aura votre humour j'ai
tout gagné